i know you're hurting at the pump gas
prices have hit all-time highs and joe
biden is refusing to allow the oil
companies to produce more to ease those
prices i know but have no fear
joe has a solution this solution will
allow you to save up to 80
per month at the pump and all you've got
to do
is buy a new electric car
under my plan
which is before the congress now we can
take advantage of the next generation of
electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about
eighty dollars a month
from not having to pay gas at the pump
now eighty dollars a month is pretty
good you have to buy a new car sure
that's expensive but 80 a month that's
pretty good so if you bought say a tesla
model x
it's a pretty prominent new electric car
that costs 106
190 to buy which is
expensive
but when you factor in the savings of 80
per month then that car will actually
pay for itself in
1328 months or roughly 111 years so just
you drive the car for 111 years and then
you're fine then you're good thank you
joe biden
you could get a less expensive model if
you would prefer you don't want to go
all the way for the model x okay you
could get a tesla model 3 that costs
forty five thousand one hundred ninety
dollars
that means that as long as you drive
that car
for 47 years you will really see some
some real savings at the pump and let's
say forget about tesla look michael
tesla that's a high-end company there's
got to be a cheaper electric car there
is there's the absolute cheapest
electric car that you could go out and
buy that's the nissan leaf that costs 28
425
which means you can start saving money
after just 30 short years this is great
you're fine stop blaming joe biden
unless you want to keep your car unless
you want to keep driving your car and
not go out and buy a new car in which
case
tough luck i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from oceanrider68
who says this is apropos my speech last
night
all justice clarence thomas has to do
is declare himself a woman and he would
be the first black female supreme court
justice this would effectively negate
the qualifications for the supreme court
of the current nominee that is true joe
biden nominated katanji jackson
because she's a black woman to be the
first female justice
clarence is frankly a sort of ambiguous
name anyway
that would be really delightful i i hope
that he does that that would make that
would get my blood flowing that would
get that would make me feel
happy and satisfied you know what else
makes me feel happy and satisfied good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles do you know what i had for
dinner
unfortunately i've been on the road this
week you know i had for dinner last week
i had delicious burgers from good
ranchers i love all their stuff from
good ranchers but the burgers are my
absolute favorite you know what kind of
burgers i had wagyu burgers that's right
high and juicy delicious
sometimes i grill it this was made in
the pan even more i just love these guys
and then i did actually right before i
flew out here we had good ranchers new
york strip steaks which were marvelous
they were absolutely marvelous the
quality of this meat is through the roof
and then the prices are shocking the
prices are so
inexpensive especially with inflation
now driving our food costs up through
the roof and then all of their meat
comes from america unlike the stuff
you're getting in the grocery store
sometimes 85 percent of that meat is not
actually made in america even if it says
it is
on every single aspect of your meat
consumption good ranchers is giving you
exactly what you want they're just
phenomenal
you can get a 30 discount right now on
prime steaks and better than organic
chicken the chicken's delicious i go to
goodranchers.com save on the quality
you've been looking for take the
guesswork out of the grocery store save
a ton of money right now
make your meat consumption inflation
proof you can subscribe if you want
right now and you're locked into your
price for life which is completely
insane go to
goodranchers.com use code knowles get
your box of 100 american meat 30 bucks
in savings combat inflation with
american meat delivered
we're we we've got a schizophrenic
energy policy right now coming out of
the white house we've got a
always a glib and ridiculous energy
policy go buy a tesla that's what you're
hearing from biden that's what you're
hearing from pete bootaj but we're also
getting an incoherent energy policy
beyond the sort of
flippant remarks about going out and
getting a model x
joe biden has decided on a policy that
actually could temporarily reduce prices
at the pump that policy will be to
release 1 million barrels of oil per day
from the u.s strategic petroleum reserve
we've had the strategic petroleum
reserve since the 1970s after there were
gas shortages we decided to stock up on
gas so we could release that gas that
would reduce the price at the pump
american consumption of oil
is 20 million barrels of oil per day
so if you release
one million barrels of oil per day okay
that's
five percent of our oil that should do
something how much oil do we have in the
petroleum reserve we have
593.6
million barrels there so biden has said
that he'll do this for up to 180 days
that would put a serious dent in the u.s
strategic petroleum reserve but hey it's
there for a reason so maybe that's what
we're going to do okay i'm not
completely knocking the policy
but you do have to wonder
why doesn't biden just let u.s oil
producers produce more oil this is an
artificial problem it's not as though
the u.s oil producers are at maximum
capacity right now and there's just
nothing we can do and it's putin's fault
that we can't get any more oil out and
it's iran's fault and it's saudi
arabia's fault it's not that's not true
it's joe biden's fault that we're not
making any more oil
it's because the the moment joe biden
came into office
he he cut it off
he said no we're not going to build more
pipelines to ship the oil
no we're not going to have new oil and
gas leases we're going to temporarily
suspend them he did that right after he
took office and then more recently he
said that that suspension is going to be
indefinite so this is an artificial
problem created by joe biden and now
it's killing biden in the polls so he's
trying to sort of reverse course he's
even making public statements
castigating the oil companies for not
making more oil the same oil that he
said they can't make more of
biden just said quote
they can put those profits to productive
use by producing more oils restarting
idle wells or producing on sites they
are already leasing
biden did admit that it takes months not
days to ramp up production
but he said
after he does this strategic release in
the meantime he wants these oil and gas
companies to start producing more oil
and the democrat line on this is that
these oil and gas companies they're
sitting on these really really
productive oil leases they just don't
want to do anything with it they've got
9 000 oil oil
permissions that they can start drilling
and they just don't want to these greedy
selfish oil companies they want more
for some reason even though those 9000
would be productive how stupid do you
need to be to notice that oil right now
is at all time highs
and the oil companies for some reason
just don't want to make money
no that's not what's going on it's that
the leases that they currently have are
not going to be
cost effective they're not going to be
productive they're not going to be
profitable another problem here is that
sometimes on some of these
oil leases they don't have any way to
transport the oil once they pump it out
of the ground and in part this is
because joe biden is killing oil
pipelines he's he's okaying oil
pipelines for vladimir putin that's what
started the war in ukraine that's even
according to the ukraine president
vladimir zelinski he said if you had not
taken the sanctions off of vladimir
putin's north stream to oil pipeline we
wouldn't have the war in ukraine so he
gives pipelines to putin but biden won't
let americans have the pipelines which
is in part why some of these oil leases
are not going to work out
but that's even besides the point
if joe biden's opinion right now is that
the oil and gas companies need to
produce more than okay give them give
them new leases but that's not he's
arguing
two contradictory points at the same
time
because
the the issue with the new oil and gas
leases is not that
that it's inefficient or that the oil
companies are sitting on old ones
joe biden's argument for not giving the
oil companies permission to pump more
oil is that it will harm the environment
it's not some sort of
economic efficiency issue here it's an
environmental issue
the argument was we do not want more oil
on the old leases on the new leases
anywhere we want to move to clean energy
we want to power our country on unicorn
tears and rainbows that was the argument
so now he's trying to have it both ways
oil companies every every gallon you
pump out of the ground is destroying the
earth and so we're going to stop you
from doing it but also what the hell is
wrong with you you got record profits
pump more out of the earth but we're not
going to give you the tools to actually
pump it out of the earth well now we're
going to release it from the petroleum
reserve well guess what when you burn
oil from the petroleum reserve it's just
as bad for the environment as when you
pump more oil
so it's
just like so much else of the biden
administration this is completely
incoherent they want to have their cake
and eat it too
and
the effect of that the practical effect
of that is
meaninglessness the practical effect of
that is they're not doing anything
productive at all totally incoherent and
speaking of incoherence in the biden
administration
our vice president our vice president
kamala harris
has just attempted to explain
economics economics specifically with
regard to jamaica please tell me if you
can decipher this
we also recognize just as it has been in
the united states for jamaica one of the
issues that has been presented as an
issue that is economic in the way of its
impact has been the pandemic
so to that end we are announcing today
also that we will assist jamaica in
covid recovery um by assisting in terms
of the recovery efforts in jamaica that
have been essential to i believe what is
necessary to strengthen not only
the the issue of public health but also
the economy
ben
ben
why did you not pack the bong in the
travel kit so that i could understand
what the vice president had to
say why this is so unprofessional i have
a kamala bong
in my desk for a reason because when she
comes out and she says things like the
economic recovery is
is designed for the recovery of in
jamaica and especially for the economy
and
we must do what we've been doing and the
time to do what we do is now to be doing
i have the bong so that i can try to
understand what the vice president is
saying but now i can't frankly i
probably couldn't
even with the bond
i am not in the studio right now i'm
just outside of a college campus i was
speaking at washburn university last
night
this was for trans visibility day the
the thrust of my speech was why
conservatives need to completely stop
tolerating transgenderism in all of its
forms everywhere for everyone uh this
excited some of the leftists on campus
there was a massive
protest before my speech
and it wasn't just protests from the
washburn community
it was protests from surrounding schools
there was actually a professor at the
university of kansas who encouraged her
students to come protest me you wanted
you want to talk about incoherence
we'll get to what was said at this
protest in just a second
first though it's uh very important
to uh listen to the people that we talk
to okay it's very important to have
respectful and civil
dialogue okay
there was a lot of shouting at this
protest last night
now when you want the productive kind of
shouting i would recommend you check out
shout out right now download the shout
out app have you ever wanted to send
your conservative uncle a fun
personalized birthday message from one
of his favorite conservative celebs have
you more importantly wanted to send your
liberal cousin
a birthday message
from one of her least favorite
conservative celebs well you can do it
now with shout out shout out is the
place to do it they've got the most
popular personalities on the right you
can get a customized video from the
likes of steven crowder ever hear about
that guy from the hodge twins jp sears
jason whitlock alex jones
that's the one i want if anyone wants to
get me a birthday present i guess my
birthday is not for about 11 months now
but uh next year i want three michael
michael i want you to have a happy
birthday don't drink the water michael
so you can get it at a shout out right
now go to the apple app store or google
play
download the shout out app and you can
easily go in there and get your favorite
conservative celebs to send that
personalized greeting for whatever it is
the birthday it's a bachelor party
whatever you want head on over get the
shout out app today
jennifer raff a professor at the
university of kansas
encouraged her students
to
show up to my speech last night at
washburn university not to listen to the
speech not to go in she didn't encourage
that at all but to protest me
outside of the speech she said hey
jayhawks
let's show our support for our neighbors
at washburn today at 4 30
ending this transphobic madness this is
a professor an associate professor of
anthropology at the university of kansas
extremely unprofessional can you imagine
what her students must think her
certainly her conservative students or
her republican students but i suspect
the vast majority of her students
because this the transgender issue is
not just a left versus right republican
versus democrat kind of issue
more than half the country knows that
men aren't women i suspect the vast vast
majority of the country knows that men
and women are different
this transgenderism issue is an issue
that
is believed by
i would estimate
10 to
20 or 30 of the country at most i'm
being as charitable as i can
but it's an issue that's believed by 100
of the ruling class so you have this
huge disparity here and this professor
is basically saying if you
believe that boys and girls are
different then you're a terrible awful
person and we are going to protest you i
might i your professor am going to go
protest you
it was a massive
protest before my speech
and then the speech went off without a
hitch i actually ended up speaking to
the organizer of one of the protests who
was a confused young lady but perfectly
polite
there were something i think the room
last night held about 350 people that
was the only downside of the speech
because there were i think a couple
hundred people who were outside who
ended up streaming the speech on their
phones outside of the room but it was a
really wonderful crowd really respectful
there were great questions i spoke to
one young woman she came up during the
question session and she said michael i
had gender dysphoria
i was really confused i was secretly
binding my body parts i was sort of
going through the process of
transitioning
and then i was diagnosed with autism
and when
people began to treat that as my
condition
my gender dysphoria went away thank god
i wasn't
brought into this
crazy world of transitioning with the
hormones and the butchery and mutilation
thank god i had a good family and a good
church that reminded me that i'm not
actually a man that i am a woman and
then they diagnosed my actual medical
condition and so i wasn't led into this
horribly destructive ideology of
transgenderism it was really amazing i
think we have the clip somewhere on the
internet we'll try to post it later on
there are lots of stories like that
specifically with people who are later
diagnosed with autism
but but with other other diagnoses as
well that are now confused for this
gender dysphoria madness
so the thrust of my speech was that
conservatives have not gone far enough
on this issue that it's not enough to
say look if you want to live your life
as a if you're a man and you want to
live your life as a woman put on a dress
and call yourself sally that's your
right that's totally fine just don't
compete in women's sports just don't do
it to kids or whatever way we've tried
to split the baby i just think that's a
losing that's a losing strategy
when we live in a society together we
need to agree about the basic facts of
society otherwise we can't have a
society if we can't agree on the
definition of man and woman we can't
communicate we can't govern ourselves we
don't really have a country and so we we
have to
reject transgenderism not just for kids
not just for college swimmers but for
everyone either it's true or it's false
that's that either the claims are true
that your
sex and gender can be different and a
man can secretly be a woman
or that's not true and we all know it's
not true and so we need to stop
tolerating it entirely it's not
respectful it's not loving it's not kind
to indulge delusions that ultimately are
going to harm people even more than
they've been harmed already
so you can check out that speech online
i think they posted under the
provocative title banning transgenderism
you can find that on yaf tv
but this is being pushed by
the elites but your professors
are
trying to get you to buy into this
frankly your kindergarten teachers now
are trying to get you to buy into this
the white house is pushing this
not just for adults even but for kids as
well the white house just came out
to endorse
sex change quote unquote surgeries
for kids
mutilating the bodies of little kids
pumping little kids full of hormones
this just out from the office of
population affairs over at the
department of health and human services
you can get it on hhs.gov
gender affirming care
and
young people
how young are we talking we're not
talking about
20 year olds we're talking about little
children
you've got social affirmation puberty
blockers hormone therapy
and gender affirming surgeries
uh you can you can read all about their
crazy ideas on the website but
i mean just just this phrase alone shows
you what they're talking about puberty
blockers that they want to give little
kids these cross-sex hormones so that
they do not develop as they ordinarily
would but become some sort of
eunuch or become some kind of
cosmetically slightly more similar to
the opposite sex person this is this is
true quackery this is true child abuse
this should be illegal and the people
perpetrating this in our government
should go to prison this is this is
really hideous stuff but why why is it
happening is it because we we
make these jokes
and i think most people are joking but
i'm not sure that
the the reason that they're doing this
is because the libs just want to diddle
your kids basically because the libs are
creepy pedophiles and they want to just
groom your kids for sexual acts maybe
that's true in some cases i don't know
but i don't think that explains the
majority of this phenomena i think the
reason they're doing this is political
i don't think it's their personal sexual
gratification
at least in the
vast majority of cases i think it's
political i think they realize that if
they can redefine sex if they can
redefine human nature
then they can redefine anything if they
can shape
five-year-olds on some of the most basic
aspects of their identity
then they can transform the world and
that's always what they're after they
always want to remake the world anew the
past is always terrible and awful and
oppressive the present is always a
crisis according to the left and the
futures are always going to be great as
long as we can make ourselves gods and
remake the whole damn world
so the white house is endorsing this
gensake the white house spokesman just
came out furious about bills that won't
let
predator adults trans the kids a bills
that we're seeing in oklahoma
bills that we're seeing in arizona she
says that these sorts of bills are
extreme and harmful they're unacceptable
and the white house won't stop fighting
for the justice and equality of chopping
off kids genitals
joe biden just rolled out gender-neutral
passports quote unquote seems like a
little bit of a national security risk
to me but there you have it the state
department is now letting american
citizens choose a third
sex
you can be male you can be female or you
can be x on your passport for people who
are neither male nor female but those
people don't exist that's not real
that's not real even in the exceedingly
rare case
of sexual or chromosomal or genital
ambiguity sometimes we call this
intersex or hermaphroditism even in that
vanishingly rare case
it's not totally ambiguous okay you can
still classify someone as male or female
and frankly that's not what this x is
going to be used for the x is not going
to be used for the infinitesimally small
percentage of people who have
sexual ambiguity
it's going to be used for people who are
quote unquote transgender where there's
no physical ambiguity whatsoever we now
have on our official identity documents
from the federal government that are
largely used for national security
purposes
this
preposterous
ideology
why because of the formerly handful of
people now it's spreading like a social
contagion but the formerly handful of
people who suffered from this kind of
confusion no it's it's for the political
revolutionary consequences of this which
is eradicating the distinction between
men and women which is something that
political leftist radicals have been
trying to do for centuries
and
i'm sorry to say it
even putatively conservative
institutions
are falling into this
you know i would never criticize fox
news
i would never do it
no
no sir not me try to get me to do it i
won't
however
well i'll ju you know what i'll do i'm
going to keep opinion
completely out of this i'm just going to
read you
what happened
fox news has hired
bruce jenner
as as caitlyn jenner
to be a political analyst for the
network
because apparently the
transgender perspective was lacking
from the putatively conservative network
this is the
again i'm not i'm not injecting my
opinion i'm just reading what they said
this is from the fox news ceo suzanne
scott
quote caitlyn's story is an inspiration
to us all
she is a trail she is a trailblazer in
the
lgbtq plus community
which i guess is a good thing and her
illustrious career spans a variety of
fields that will be an asset tremendous
asset for our audience i'm humbled by
this unique opportunity to speak
directly to fox news media's millions of
viewers about a range of issues that are
important to the american people
like transgender like the affirmation of
transgenderism
with conservatives like this one wonders
why we have a native liberals in fox's
defense by the way
it it would appear that
fox has been telling the truth the whole
the fox says fox says they're not i'm
not a conservative network we're not
pushing conservatism we're fair and
balanced we're sort of a centrist
network
and the left always made fun of them for
saying this and saying no you're not
you're a far right network you're not
you're not centrist you're not fair and
balanced well
well i think they're pro i don't know
about
i don't know about whatever slogan you
want to use but it would seem that
they're ascent a more centrist network
that has a lot of democrats on the
payroll and is now presenting very
radical far-left ideologies like
transgenderism in a way that is
affirming those ideologies using
pronouns she to refer to men who think
that they're women
it's not it's not just the far left
elite established institutions that are
pushing this thing as i have warned you
from the beginning hate to say i told
you so putting on my nostradamus ad here
it's it's basically
might be entirely all
of the elite established institutions
are pushing an ideology that the vast
majority of americans correctly know is
completely insane
now
speaking of men and women
clarence thomas is in big trouble
supreme court justice clarence thomas
probably the favorite justice among the
conservatives the left hates him he's
the least favorite justice for the
leftists
well aaron rupar
who formerly was with vox.com i think
he's an independent left-wing journalist
now
he's got the smoking gun
you see because clarence thomas's wife
jenny thomas is active in conservative
politics
clarence thomas he's a judge
on the supreme court
the left always wants him to recuse
himself from cases because ginny thomas
is involved in politics and that's and
clarence thomas he's not allowed to
talk about the law if his wife is in
politics
and now they've got a clip of clarence
thomas admitting in an interview
that he relies
upon his wife as uh as almost like a
sort of the other half of his person
almost sort of like part of of his one
flesh because they're in a marriage
together
and the best part of being a justice
it's first of all it's um
it'd be impossible
without you
i have to be honest i mean it would be
um
it's sort of like how do you run with
one leg
you can't i in the
um
it makes it whole
when i have my wife
ha ha we got him we got him recuse
yourself justice thomas you just
admitted you
love your wife
ha ha
that's a that is a shocking revelation
apparently to some liberals
that a man would love his wife first of
all that's shocking to some liberals but
also that a man would speak in these
terms you're like the other half of me
it
being without you would be like having
one leg
this this actually i really believe is
shocking to liberals i think a lot of
liberals
will understand that the man loves his
wife someone
but very few liberals i suspect will
understand marriage in this way which is
the traditional way
it's the christian way which is that
man and woman leave their families and
join together and what god has joined
let no man separate and they become one
flesh
they really are
part of one another
that
because the way that the libs today
conceive of marriage is that it's a
contract just like any other contract
you you form an accounting firm
with your friend well that's a contract
you
agree to have a party catered by the
local baker that's a contract and you
engage in a marriage that's a contract
too that contract can be dissolved for
whatever reason you don't need to prove
false you can have a no fault
dissolution no fault divorce in that
marriage if you're no longer being
fulfilled if you no longer really like
one another you've got totally separate
lives often you've got totally separate
bank accounts you both just pursue your
careers however you want and when the
marriage becomes inconvenient i guess it
has to dissolve
that's
the way that the libs conceive of
marriage today
marriage has nothing to do with sexual
complementarity
everywhere throughout all of human
history uh marriage has been understood
to involve a husband and a wife
uh now no longer just two people because
people can sign contracts men and women
are basically the same that's what
transgenderism tells us that's what all
of the elites tell us now so
no big deal
no big deal right
wrong
wrong
clarence thomas is right he obviously
should not recuse himself for loving his
wife and having uh apparently at least a
relatively normal marriage compared to
what everyone else
in in the elite circles has they're
shocked they're absolutely shocked at
him speaking of men and women and
loyalty jd vance who's the author of
hillbilly elegy he's running for senate
in ohio now he's running on a much more
conservative platform culturally
conservative platform than many other
republicans he's in hot water because
you see marjorie taylor green
she spoke at a conference
that had all sorts of nasty people at it
and she didn't say anything wrong at the
conference she did no one really objects
but she was associating with people who
are mean and nasty and terrible and so
the left basically wants to cancel her
and is is trying to get anyone who's
associated with her to condemn marjorie
taylor green not for saying anything
wrong or doing anything wrong but
appearing in an event that was
unsavory
jd vance refuses to do that
is highlight something karen that i
really don't like that the media does
and they do it to republicans of course
they never do it to democrats which is
they play this guilt by association game
where they get us to stab our friends in
the back and then we wonder why the left
always wins even though we sometimes win
elections because we're constantly
stabbing our friends in the back
the accusation against marjorie is
pretty simple that she appeared at a
conference where somebody said something
bad and i asked did she say something
bad at the conference i actually watched
the remarks i agreed with nearly every
word that she said i hate this about
politics
i was raised by my mama she's a great
woman
she's from southeastern kentucky she
called us hillbillies growing up and she
told us that the thing that mattered
more more than anything was loyalty
there's no business in the world that
asks you to stab your friends in the
back like politics i absolutely refuse
to do it to marjorie taylor green she is
my friend and she did nothing wrong she
said nothing wrong and i'm absolutely
not going to throw her under the bus or
anybody else who's a friend of mine i
love this response
because he's totally
ignoring whatever
claims the libs are making whatever
guilt by association by association by
association claims the libs are making
about marge retailer green he's saying
hey did marjorie taylor green say
something
wrong no she didn't she said she just
said completely mainstream things she
just showed up to an event one event
among probably hundreds that she does
every year that because you can have
guilt by association association
association you're you're going to try
to get me someone who's sort of
associated with her to condemn her no i
don't think i'm going to do that
no i don't i and he says something so
important
people really ought to keep this in mind
loyalty matters
loyalty matters in your personal life
and in politics frankly
it matters
to a very high degree in both it
probably matters more in politics but
there's a great temptation in politics
to throw your friends under the bus the
first time that it's convenient the
first time you catch a little heat
because your
your buddy does something wrong your
political ally does something wrong or
is even accused of doing something wrong
then all of a sudden we throw everyone
under the bus the libs don't have this
problem
the libs stick together
when they do things that are very wrong
actually they stick together i don't
have time to get really into this today
we'll have to get to it next week but
give you an example of this
the hunter biden laptop
was completely real the entire liberal
establishment said it was completely
fake and they called it disinformation
and they shut it down and i would
suspect most of them knew that it was
real but they lied and they all covered
up for one another the hunter biden
laptop which now even the new york times
even the washington post admits is real
shows that not only was he profiting
from crooked contracts from the the
corrupt ukrainian oligarchs not only was
he profiting all around the world with
his father's name but he was making
millions of dollars from china
previously we had been told he he didn't
actually solve the deal with china that
he that it was just on the table but he
didn't actually make any money no it
turns out the guy made just under 5
million bucks from the chinese from a
crooked chinese energy company between
2017 and 2018 that was in a retainer and
in consulting fees and by the way he was
holding big chunks of
of equity
valuable assets for his father 10 held
by h for the big guy that's the line
that no one wants you to talk about
we'll get it into more of the hunter
biden laptop next week
just a reminder that in in forget about
guilt by association you showed up to
some conference someone said something
at the conference we're talking about
extraordinarily high level corruption
with national security implications in
china in ukraine from russia that the
son of the president was doing
potentially to benefit the president
himself and the entire liberal media
stick together and it was politically
very effective so if they're going to do
that with things that are extremely
unjust and immoral and corrupt can't we
do that when we don't need to
do things that are unjust when we don't
need to do things that are corrupt we
don't need to do things that are immoral
when we just need to stick by our
friends and allies in politics i think
we can i believe conservatives can and i
think that we should it'll help everyone
sleep easier at night kind of like when
you sleep on bolin branch sheets right
now go to bowlandbranch.com
promo code michael bowlin branch are the
greatest sheets i have ever slept on i
love them i got a freebie early on when
we started this show and like a like a
drug dealer they got me hooked and now i
buy them they're so they're so amazing
i've learned a lot about sheets did you
know for instance you always you always
hear about this
the thread count you always hear about
the thread count in the sheets did you
know thread count doesn't matter really
at all what matters is the quality of
the threads that's much more important
and with bowl and branch you are getting
the top quality best 100
organic cotton threads on earth a far
superior softness for a great night's
sleep multiple u.s presidents have slept
on bowling brand sheets more importantly
i sleep on bowling brand sheets i
absolutely love them
they've got over 10 000 stellar reviews
they're 100 free from toxins no
pesticides none of that all those harsh
chemicals it's just amazing you get a 30
night risk free trial with free shipping
and returns on all orders
try it out you're going to love it
you're going to at the end of 30 days
you're going to order more sheets get 15
off your first set of sheets use promo
code michael mich ael at bowlin branch
dot com b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code michael
you know i'm not the biggest sports guy
in the world but i love
this new sports podcast from the daily
wire that is crane and company and
craning company right now is headed down
to the final four they've got a big tour
bus it's big and brash and bold and
quintessentially daily wire and it's a
finger right in the nose finger right in
the eye of espn and disney and all these
woke people who have not only ruined
entertainment they've not only ruined
the movies and the tv shows they've
ruined sports too and so we're going
down there and we've got our own sports
offerings and it's going to be a lot
more popular so you can tune in live
today at 3 p.m eastern and you can tune
in every day at dailywire.com on uh or
if you if you want to go on the daily
wires youtube channel or if you want to
go on apple podcast or if you want to go
wherever you get your audio podcasts
make sure to subscribe to crane and
company leave a five star review we will
be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the show my uh we we are
now in my favorite time of the week that
would be the mail bag first question up
from ben
hey michael my wife and i are in our 20s
and are very happy with just the two of
us we've talked about kids but neither
of us are sure we actually want them as
christians we are obligated are we
obligated slash called slash supposed to
have children we're not sold on having
kids but we also want to live a life and
have a marriage pleasing to god thank
you for all you do we love the show
that's so
uh
wonderful to hear this question thank
you for the compliment and i love this
question in particular because there's a
very simple answer yes have kids
that's it we can move on right now
not everyone in a marriage gets to have
kids a lot of people don't get to have
kids a lot of people struggle with
infertility and it's extremely painful
for them
but everyone in a marriage has an
obligation to be open to life
to be open
to being fruitful and to multiplying to
giving of your love and yourself
entirely to the other person to your
spouse to your other half without
holding anything back
yes you do have that obligation i
sympathize with you i empathize with you
frankly because you're in your 20s and
you're having fun and you're going to
brunch and you're going out and having a
good time and you're living that dink
lifestyle double income no kids
potentially and you can go on fun
vacations and you can go to nice
restaurants and that's great and it's
fun and i did it myself
in my 20s and it's so great isn't it to
not have a lot of responsibilities and
to go on and do it but two points on
that
one
ultimately that will not be fulfilling
ultimately you'll get sick of the
mimosas
uh two
marriage is not just about pleasing
yourself this is a trap that the libs
fall into the if you believe that the
purpose of marriage is just to give
yourself a lot of pleasure and then
and then that's it then what happens
when the pleasure runs out what happens
when they stop refilling the mimosas
what happens when you get tired of going
to the same restaurant for the 500th
time
then what are you doing
marriage is about building something
about coming together and
becoming something different than you
were the man and just like the sperm and
the ag come together and they create
something different than they were
previously something totally unique the
same is true of a marriage you leave
your family your wife leaves her family
you come together and you form something
new it's a new family
and you do something and you grow just
like that little baby is going to grow
in the womb your family is going to grow
you may not be able to have kids a lot
of people are really surprised when they
decide in their 20s they don't want kids
in their 30s they decide we do want kids
and they're shocked to find out that
it's harder than it looks and maybe they
can't have kids
and then you talk about where to go from
there i'm not saying everyone is called
to that
i'm not saying everyone's called to
marriage for that matter but if you are
i would strongly recommend you do the
thing there is actually no ambiguity on
this so uh best of luck have lots of
babies this is also the other way we're
going to beat the libs i remember i was
a teenager and we saw indiana governor
mitch daniels
he said governor daniels how do we beat
the libs they said well you can either
outfox them you know out persuade them
out maneuver them in politics that's
tricky they're pretty clever or you can
outbreed them and i would recommend the
latter because the latter is more fun so
try that from frank i met the point of
baptizing my baby and i was wondering
how baptizing a baby is not abuse in the
sense that he's not consenting to it
maybe he will grow and decide to follow
another religion or be an atheist should
we wait until he's an adult to baptize
him thanks for your time
i know a lot of people in the audience
probably do not agree with infant
baptism
infant baptism of course has been
practiced throughout the entire history
of the church going back to its earliest
days it is found in scripture when you
hear in the book of acts for instance of
whole households being baptized it's
alluded to i certainly believe and is it
is traditionally understood to be uh
found in scripture when christ says let
the little children come to be not just
the children who are rational and
consent and they're past the age of
maturity and they're in their teenage
years but the little children too
uh but beyond beyond anyone's qualms
with infant baptism that's actually not
the point of this question
the point of this question is should i
do something
to or for my child that he can't consent
to and the answer to that is
duh of course
is it morally licit to do something to
her for my child without his consent yes
of course that's everything you do for
your child i don't think your child
consents to nap time all the time i
don't think your child probably consents
to eating his broccoli
but you have him do that anyway because
that's what it means to raise a child
that's what it means to educate someone
education is in many ways coercive
i don't think your child is picking out
his clothing you're you are coercing
your child to wear his winter jacket
when it's snowy outside
you're making decisions for your child
because that child is in your care and
you are raising that child
the same is true in your
in his
academic education and certainly true in
his religious life
even beyond the question of baptism are
you going to take the child to church
he's not consenting to it
how do you know that one day he won't
decide that he wants to be a jew or a
muslim or a hindu
so isn't it wrong to take him to church
spending all of his sundays at church
are you going to read the bible to your
child or have your child read the bible
was it what if he doesn't want to what
if he wants to end up becoming a
buddhist
he won't he won't even have that choice
if you don't educate him
this is even beyond the question of
religion this is one of the paradoxes of
education is that the point of education
is to make you free
but the only way to become educated is
to be forced to be educated the only way
to become educated is to get a slap on
the wrist to get bad grades if you don't
do your homework to be forced to do your
homework to be forced to read the book
to be forced to follow the curriculum
even when you'd rather go play outside
at recess
but only through that process of shaping
and and coercion let's call it what it
is then one can be free and then one
actually can choose so
then beyond that there's actually
another question raised by this
issue which is why do you want to
baptize your child
presumably you want to baptize your
child because you believe in jesus and
you think that jesus is the way in the
truth and the life and people who are
within the body of christ have life in
them and people who are outside of it
don't have life in them and this is the
way that your child is going to have
eternal life and this is the way that
your child is going to be close to his
god and you believe it's true and good
for him
presumably that's why you want it i
don't think it's just because you want
to have a fun lunch after this kind of
strange religious ceremony no you want
to do it because you think it's true and
good
so then do it that's for the good of
your child
not everything in life is about consent
there
it is important that we
cultivate our free will and be able to
make good decisions
but there is also just a question of
good and bad and right and wrong and
especially and true and false for that
matter and when you're raising a kid
you want to cultivate those things in
your child you want to cultivate virtue
you want your child to pursue good you
want your child to pursue the truth you
want to have him pursue the things that
are right
and and that involves shaping his very
will shaping his desire when kids are
poorly educated
the effect of that is that their desires
are for bad things
it's not just that they're doing bad
things it's that they're actively
desiring those bad things this is what
happens with addiction
i don't have any desire for heroin
i don't i'm not saying i don't have
desires for bad things we all do it's a
fallen world but i don't have any desire
for heroin i've never done heroin i bet
if i did heroin right now i would
well i don't really like needles so i
wouldn't probably like it very much the
first time
but if i did it once twice three times i
bet i would start to desire that heroin
that's called addiction and my very
desire would be turned for something
that was harmful and destructive so
you're shaping the desire of your child
you're shaping the very way that his
consent and his free will will work all
of which is a long way of saying get
your kid baptized from sam dear michael
i sometimes struggle with overthinking
about my past and second guessing things
i did not did not do or chances i did
not take i don't want to have regrets in
life so i wanted to ask your advice on
how to not have regrets in the future
and moving on from having regrets
in your past sincerely no regrets good
question because you're asking about two
things you're asking about the regrets
for the things you did do
and regrets for the things you didn't do
there's a line in glengarry glenn ross
which in the movie version is played by
al pacino
and and the line is you regret the
things you don't do
you gotta
so you regret the things that you don't
do and a lot of people think that that's
true and
i suppose that's true but you also
regret the things that you do do
if those things are wrong and shameful
we all have regrets for things that we
did that we wish we didn't do
and a great many people regret
regret opportunities that they missed
chances they allowed to pass by
the girl you're the one that got away
a lot of people have those things every
everyone has those things in one way or
another
how do you move on from it well one
there is some solace in knowing that
that's inevitable that's the way this
fallen world works
you're going to screw up you're going to
regret
you're lucky if you regret the things
that you screwed up because it means
you've at least had a kind of repentance
it means you at least have a working
moral conscience it means at least you
have a kind of clarity so that's good
actually having regrets is the first
step on the road to recovery
and then the question is what are you
going to do about it you can't change
the past you can change the future so
you can change your behavior but then
ultimately at a spiritual level you need
absolution you need redemption this is
the essence of christianity
and so how are you going to do that
well
the christian understanding is that
christ died for your sins and you can be
absolved of your sins all of your sins
even your worst terrible blackest sins
if you turn toward christ and accept him
and the way i would recommend doing that
is receiving the sacraments joining the
church going to confession it's like the
laundromat for your souls and going
forth and sinning no more and then you
are going to send some more and then
you're going to repent again
and you're going to turn your desire
just like we were talking about in the
last question you're going to turn your
desire slowly toward toward holiness and
toward goodness that would be my
that would be my suggestion
you you should actually take comfort in
the fact that you have those regrets
don't mire in those regrets the devil is
always trying to pull you back to the
past pull you back to all the terrible
things that you've done
you should actually
in some ways rejoice when you have those
regrets
because they're a warning post they're a
recognition of things you don't want to
do again and then go seek salvation
you're not going to get it
in and of yourself so you're going to
have to find it elsewhere in your god no
two ways about it sometimes
people
i fear that people get a little tired of
my religious talk because we're talking
about politics all right we're talking
about culture talking about personal
behavior why does it come back to
religion so often because all human
conflict is theological and so if you
want if you want these ultimate answers
it's going to have to get to that that's
been true in every culture everywhere in
the world for all of human history i
know that people now they're really
enlightened and they're really smart and
they've got dr fauci and they've got
science so they don't need religion but
those people are big dumb idiots and you
do so if you want the ultimate answers
you're going to have to dig in that
deeply
from anonymous okay dear general knowles
another relationship question for you
i recently met a nice girl at a local
bar we hit it off well during the convo
we realized that we have the same
interests and values when i asked her if
she listens to any podcasts she
immediately brought up the michael
knowles show a refreshing surprise i'm
gonna pause it there marry her she's a
great girl
she's smart she's got a good head on her
shoulders she'll raise up great kids
okay i'll finish the question
we're both catholic we even share the
same heritage half irish and half
italian
it's almost too good to be true we
danced all night and shared more than a
few good night kisses
she seems a bit shy and i really don't
want to mess anything up my question for
you is how do i best walk the line
between showing her that i'm interested
and not coming on too strong sincerely a
military man without a plan this time
don't worry bro come on are you kidding
me i think you're fine i don't you know
don't show up outside our bedroom window
with a boom box but that would be a
little aggressive but yeah go ask around
and get some more drinks frankly it
sounds like you really hit it off so
skip the drinks go straight to dinner
right you know ask her out on a date go
get nice dinner pick up the check i
probably don't need to tell you this
you're a military man you're you listen
to my show you are you are a man of
faith i think you would understand this
generally but you know act like a man
act like a gentleman you don't want to
seem desperate you're not desperate but
you're interested you're eager you're
attracted to this girl you're confident
girls like that okay you don't need to
you don't need to worry about playing
koi you're not a 12 year old all right
you're you know you're a man you know
what you want you want the right stuff
you want to go get it enjoy i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see you on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin